want to make sure that every book that I
write is as good as or better than the
last one and I feel myself coming to an
end of my natural material Nantucket is
four miles wide and 13 miles long you're
running out of ideas running out of
material yeah and I just want to make
sure I go out on a very high yeah yeah I
I mean I imagine okay but what if you
move from Nantucket to someplace else
well it's not impossible right never
saying it well so then what are you
going to do in retirement given you're
already churning your own butter
well I've started I'm starting a podcast
which launches tomorrow and it's called
books the beach and Beyond with my work
husband Tim talks books and it's a big
swing literary podcast we have Ann
Patchett we have Colleen Hoover we have
Taylor Jenkins we have Gilbert Cruz who
is the editor of the New York Times book
review did an interview so I'm gonna
that's where I'm sort of focus my energy
but aren't you and your daughter how old
is your daughter she's 17. 17. aren't
you and your daughter doing something
together yeah so we're gonna write two
novels set at a New England boarding
school